she has a lady boner as do I boner City
this is the sexiest signature I told you
is a good dancer
I just remember seeing devon Sawa and
like sweating and not knowing how to
stop it and feeling really uncomfortable
because my mother was next to me the
music alone is it's sex music for all
the times I've been a genuine jerk this
is a real apology I realize his voice is
like I thought it was much deeper he's
still really hot he's like 38 I think
but he's like I'd still go for it you
see these things and you're not it's not
clear why they're mesmerizing until much
later when you see them again and you're
like oh it's softcore porn the people of
Eternia shall see you kneeling to me I'm
living new to you yes you will
Oh Oh this is Wow
this explains a lot I have a diary entry
here from like 1991 where I'm like seven
okay Barry
today I think I'll tell you about rocky
rocky and bullwinkle my first crush in a
cartoon character like the first of many
oh well I've in bed with my pretend
friend Rocky
Wow it's kind of dirty actually I just
want to be very clear that I am NOT a
furry but I do remember watching
Chippendales Rescue Rangers and seeing
the character gadget and being like
she's different than the other
characters isn't she what's going on
here
good morning gadget Oh so chipping down
there what's up so it's not just me who
was attracted to gadget there it is
take off that mask girl oh she's so
attract he was so honest and so he was a
really nice guy he's kind of a deadbeat
I think that's the point which also
explains my attraction to deadbeats to
this day it's just like asking to stare
at people's crotches this is if you have
a show for kids that has lots of hot
people being really sweaty and
aggressive it's very hard not to be
sexually awakened I'm still giddy I'm
giddy right now he's maybe 12 in this
movie sorry it's a very hot manner I
feel like a cat extremely hot in here